il est 15 heures 45 sur l'aéroport de
berlin rangsdorf il fait une chaleur
accablante et là près d'un téléphone
voilà un colonel de l'armée allemande et
il vient de demander un numéro il attend
ce colonel est un grand blessé de guerre
mutilés il lui manque un bras et lui
manque un oeil et de l'unique main qui
lui reste il n'a que trois doigts il
tient justement le téléphone dans ces
trois doigts
la sonnerie retentit au loin il attend
on décroche et alors il parle
alors ici stauffenberg et la voix une
voix angoissée qui répond alors que
stauffenberg à son tour hitler est mort
[Musique]
c'est stauffenberg revient de prusse
orientale
très exactement du repaire du loup c'est
à dire le quartier général d'hitler
il est sûr qu hitler est mort parce
qu'il a déposé lui-même une bombe au
pied de hitler et de loin il a vu
exploser
il est sincère mais ils se trompent
hitler n'a pas été tué par la bombe et
pourtant tout un groupe de conjurer
travaillé depuis des mois à cet attentat
logiquement il avait mis tous les atouts
dans leur jeu logiquement ils devraient
être morts
il ne l'est pas pourquoi
il y avait des années que des hommes en
allemagne s'opposer à étaient des civils
et aussi des militaires ils s'opposaient
dans l'ombre bien sûr mais le principal
de ses opposants devenus des conjurés
bien justement c'est celui qui était là
près du téléphone
c'est stauffenberg claus comte von
stauffenberg l'une des plus anciennes
familles de l'aristocratie allemande
[Musique]
elle commet 113,182 et depuis les
stauffenberg qui se sont succédé sans
interruption en ligne directe le père de
stauffenberg était grand maréchal à la
cour de würth un bain et lui-même avec
ses frères un grandi dans un climat
assez singulier vous savez l'allemagne
là l'image traditionnelle des
aristocrates allemand elle est double il
y à des soldats dans ces familles là
mais aussi des artistes et claus von
stauffenberg adore la musique il joue du
violoncelle cependant que l'un de ses
frères et violoniste l autre pianiste
on donne des concerts au château des
chutes hoffenberg et puis klaus
rencontre la poésie
il devient le disciple de stéphane georg
un très grand poète allemand logiquement
tout cela ne devrait pas le conduire à
devenir soldat et pourtant il suit la
tradition de la famille il entre à
l'école des cadets de bamberg le voilà
officiers
en 1933 il se marie avec une baronne qui
lui donnera cinq enfants
[Musique]
en 1933 justement c'est l'arrivée de
hitler au pouvoir
[Applaudissements]
comment stauffenberg accueille-t-il
heatley en vérité les monarchistes donc
il est sur la réserve
c'est plus tard qu'il va racheter hitler
après 1938 quand on commence à
pourchasser les juifs en allemagne la
fameuse nuit de cristal il n'est pas
d'accord stauffenberg et cela l'honore
[Musique]
il n'est pas d'accord non plus sur cette
hitler qui va jeter l'allemagne dans la
guerre
et pourtant ils soldats il va la faire
cette mais quand il va voir en russie ce
qui s'y passe
les massacres systématiques d'ukrainiens
les prisonniers russes traités comme des
animaux
[Musique]
les juifs massacrés par centaines de
milliers
[Musique]
alors là non théophane baird basque
il est quand il estime que la présence
vite les à la tête de l'allemagne est
une tache sur le drapeau allemand et
c'est alors qu'il rencontre deux hommes
qui partagent exactement cette opinion
mais qui sont allés plus loin que lui
stauffenberg
c'est le général von trench coat et son
beau frère
fabián fanshop brenders mais ils sont
allés plus loin ils sont passés à
l'action
ils ont déposé une bombe dans l'avion
dit lei
et la bombe n'a pas explosé vers 8 voix
lasse et ça ait l'air cette chance qui
l'accompagnent depuis le premier jour
depuis le jour de son accession au
pouvoir
[Musique]
que nous appellerions nous la baraka il
a la baraka heatley mais voilà c'est que
fritsch qu'offre la brenne d'orphée
stauffenberg maintenant se sont
rencontrés et c'est très important pour
la suite c'est capital
steinberg est d'accord pour agir mais il
soldats il est nommé lieutenant colonel
est envoyé en afrique du nord
en tunisie c'est la fin de l'épopée de
l'afrika corps
[Musique]
et là sur le fond d'afrique sa voiture
va être mitraillés par un avion alliés
il ya laissé pour presque mort on le
transporte
par acquis de conscience à l'hôpital de
carthage c'est moribond a perdu déjà un
oeil on sauve l'autre on lui coupe un
bras en préserv les trois doigts de
l'autre main on le transporte à
l'hôpital de munich il s'en sort mais il
déclare à sa fin tu sais sur mon lit
d'hôpital j'ai beaucoup réfléchi je
pense que le moment est venu pour moi de
servir de faire quelque chose pour
l'allemand je dois vous dire qu'une
bonne partie du souvenir de mon père
remonte à l'époque de la guerre lorsque
la guerre a commencé j'avais 5 ans et
lorsque mon père est mort
j'avais 10 ans et durant cette période
bien sûr il était fort peu à la maison
il ne venait que pour les quelques
congés très court qu'il avait il est
resté un petit peu plus longtemps
lors de sa blessure en 1943 et puis
après sa guérison il est resté assez
longtemps ici à la hot line
avant de rejoindre sa nouvelle
affectation à berlin comment était mon
père eh bien c'était le père le père
idéal
le père que nous avons beaucoup aimé
il ne nous est jamais venu à l'esprit
qu'il peut être autre
normalement il doit être réformé il ne
veut pas être réformé et c'est le
général von fritsch coffre qu'ils
retrouvent à ce moment précis qui va le
faire nommer à l'état major du général
olbricht à berlin olbricht qui est lui
même
allan schinazi forcené et trench cov
sait très bien ce qu'il fait
trets qu'officie l agent du destin dans
le civil trench-coat était un agent de
change et surtout un ami un admirateur
du général bec
j'ai prononcé le nom du général bec et
bien en le prononçant gens trop plein de
la conspiration
en 1938 le général beck était chef
d'état major général de l'armée allemand
poste capital
c'était un grand stratège d'un grand
soldat un homme honnête
il savait parfaitement qu'il clair
préparer la guerre et il était affolé
parce qu'il le savait parce qu'ils
savaient que cette guerre si l'allemagne
entre et l'allemagne la perdre et parce
qu'il voyait plus loin que d'éventuels
victoire et le voyait le monde entier
peut appeler démocratie ce uni et
l'allemagne ne pourraient pas venir à
bout du monde entier et par deux fois
beck l'honnête bête l'honnête général
beck avait adressé au général von
brauchitsch des notes
demandant que tout le corps des
officiers allemands
si nice pour empêcher une claire de
faire la guerre
[Musique]
où
et la seconde fois éclair en lisant la
note avait dit monsieur le général beck
s'est mis en état de rébellion qu'il en
tire les conséquences beck avait
démissionné et là dans le civil dans sa
retraite il s'est désespéré qui
arrêterait heatley dans sa folie c'est
alors qu'il avait rencontré karl gher de
l'air et bien voilà un autre nom qui va
compter dans cette histoire car le gars
de l'heure c'est un fonctionnaire devenu
maire de leipzig à démocrates
conservateurs qui avait été nommé par
hitler en 1934 commissaire à la
surveillance des prix du rage
cela ne voulait pas dire qu'ils
approuvaient la preuve c'est que dès
l'arrivée des nazis au pouvoir
le maire de l'haÿ psych avait protégé
des commerçants juifs molesté par les
usa et que plus tard quand les nazis
avaient voulu enlever d'une place de
leipzig
la statue du compositeur juif
mendelssohn girl a l'air plutôt que de
l'accepter avait démissionné geste qui
l'honore
au moment de faire ses adieux à ses
collaborateurs guerdat leur a dit qu
cette démission signifie la fin de ma
vie publique et a bien fait de prononcer
le mot public parce que maintenant ce
sera une vie clandestine qui sera la
sienne il rencontre des personnalités en
france en angleterre en belgique et à
tous il dit il y à des opposants
l'allemagne il faut les aider il faut
faciliter leur tâche parce que ce sont
ses opposants la qui peuvent empêcher
hitler de faire la guerre mais on le
coûte à peine il ya d'autres gens qui au
même moment font les mêmes démarches par
exemple le comte von moltke d'une très
grande famille allemand et fabien phone
schlamme reinsdorf et oui le monde est
petit nous leur trouvons et eux vont
frapper à d'autres portes
cela brender fait même reçu par
churchill et plaident la cause des
opposants allemands des résistants
allemands et churchill le vieux winston
qui sait très bien voir les choses
clairement de dire eh bien qu'ils se
montrent vos amis après on verra bah oui
on tourne en rond et d'autres
interviennent frappe aussi à des portes
et personne ne les entends et la guerre
éclate
et d'ailleurs ses opposants tous
mobilisés ou presque tous se mueront en
bon soldat
avec ce paradoxe qui les suit partout
nous servent l'allemagne mais il a ici
plein
et c'est le moment où justement certains
décident de passer à l'action et c'est
le moment où après ses blessures
jetant feinberg vient d'être nommé à
berlin l'adjoint du général al rifi
[Musique]
c'est le moment où il comprend qu'il se
trouve un poste extraordinaire parce que
olbrich tout simplement commande l'armée
de l'intérieur parce que les soldats
allemands qui ne sont pas sur les fronts
ray bien ils sont sur le territoire
allemand ils dépendent
ils obéiront aubryste quand olbricht
leur donnera l'ordre d'effectuer telle
ou telle manoeuvre et il y à mieux
encore vous savez qu'il y a des millions
de travailleurs étrangers en allemagne
[Musique]
et un jour le commandement de la
wehrmacht s'est posé la question de
savoir ce qui se passerait si ces
travailleurs étrangers se révolter
y'a pas une chance sur mille parce
qu'ils n'ont rien n'ont pas d'armes sont
pas organisés mais enfin à commandement
bien compris doit prévoir une chance
même s'il n'existe qu'une sur 1000
c'est à dire l'amiral canard east le
chef de l'ap vers lui même
casio pose en contre hitler qui a
signalé ce danger alors on l'a mis sur
pied un plan qui permettrait en cas d'
d'insurrection de rebellions hat est
limité à tel autre à tel autre encore de
manoeuvrer à travers l'allemagne de se
rendre à l'endroit qui lui est fixé
auparavant pour juguler l'insurrection
et c'est ce qu'on a appelé l'opération
walkyrie elle est entièrement préparé
sur le papier chaque commandement
d'unités a reçu ses ordres chacun sait
que le cas échéant il faudra obéir au
général olbricht pour effectuer
l'opération walkyrie et oui on le brise
et stéphane bern ont en plus entre les
mains cette arme fabuleuse que
l'opération walkyrie mais stauffenberg
pense qu'on ne peut pas déclencher
aucune opération militaire à berlin ou
autour de berlin ou dans le reste de
l'allemagne
sans avoir auparavant éliminé heatley il
peut en convaincre ceux qui se
réunissent maintenant au tour de coeur
de leur retour du général bec au tour
d'autres et savez-vous où ils se
réunissent dans les bureaux de l'abwehr
et oui c'est incroyable mais c'est ainsi
et puis quand tu ne peuvent pas se
réunir dans les bureaux de la berre et
bien ils se réunissent sur le comte von
malte en silésie dans cette propriété de
cry zoo et bientôt on parlera du cercle
de kratzer et il ya maintenant des
hommes importants dans ce cercle
on peut parler vraiment le conjuration
il y a le maréchal von witzleben il y a
le chef de la police de berlin
le comte von elles doivent changer ce
que cela
il y à aussi en général dans le
commandement peut se révéler capital car
ils commandent à paris le général von
stülpnagel bah oui tous ces gens se
réunissent et on discute un peu trop
longuement il faut bien le dire par
exemple on n'est pas d'accord d'abord
sur le fait qu'il faut tuer hitler et on
voudrait l'enlever l'arrêter et le faire
juger par un tribunal secret c'est
stauffenberg qui lors du met enfin
coûteux soyons sérieux
qu'est ce que ça veut dire votre
histoire vous n'arriverez jamais à rien
il faut tuer hitler
les autres finissent par en convenir
alors il faut trouver un exécuteur
difficile parce que ceux à qui l'on
s'adresse
qui sont tous prêts à faire le sacrifice
de leur vie c'est pas le problème
ils hésitent sur le plan des principes
ils disent ben oui mais le führer et
commandant en chef c'est le commandant
suprême de l'armée
est-ce que sa mort subite ne va pas
désorganiser nos forces et nous mettre
en position d'infériorité pour traiter
avec nos ennemis évidemment ça se défend
comme aux hommes alors on en est là et
steinberg regarde du côté des civils de
la conspiration ils sont nombreux mais
il estime qu' ils sont tous un peu trop
conservateur ça c'est un parfum de
passéisme cette conjuration et geof
enberg demande que l'on intègre dans le
futur gouvernement qui est déjà fixé
organisé il y aura le général beth comme
président du raje gain de l'air sera le
chancelier et c'est enfin là qui demande
qu'il y ait un socialiste est il le
désigne et un chef syndicaliste et il le
désigne les deux hommes sont absorbés
dans le gouvernement
car de plus en plus il faut bien le dire
ses shoots hoffenberg
qui exerce son autorité il regarde aussi
du côté des militaires il trouve que le
général beth que l'on vient d'opérer
gravement pour un cancer qui se remet
peu à peu qui termine sa convalescence
ils seront pourtant qu'il est bien
fatigué mais il est nécessaire qu'il
soit là le général bec c'est un soldat
illustrer sa signature au bas de
certains ordres peut galvaniser certains
chefs d'unité donc bravo c'est un
drapeau mais ce n'est pas lui qui jouera
un rôle actif alors une regarde ailleurs
et il estime qu'il faut des maréchaux et
on arrive prendre contact avec le
maréchal von klum qui écoutent
favorablement les offres qu'on lui fait
le maréchal modèle même attitude et on
en vient au maréchal rebelles
[Musique]
romel c'est le héros populaire par
excellence
c'est lui qui dans un temps de barbarie
inouïe a conduit une guerre un solide en
afrique du nord une guerre chevalerie
[Musique]
et a conquis l'estiment de ses propres
ennemis
[Musique]
alors promet et bien rebelles commandes
en france c'est lui qui doit faire face
au futur département et il a retrouvé
deux hommes qui sont ses amis qui sont
le général von hofsten à coeur et puis
aussi fall kane house qui tous les deux
ont des conduites et tous les deux vont
lui parler et d'abord il se tait ne
s'engage pas et puis un jour quand même
il parle avec son chef d'état major
général steisel qui est lui même membre
de la conspiration voyez il a beaucoup
et l'acceptent d'avoir des contacts élan
vers hp et dell auprès des chiffres link
est un ami de coeur délais il donnera
son accord
il est convenu que après l'élimination
du club
il n'est d'ailleurs pas d'accord pour
qu'on le tue il dit qu'il faut l'arrêter
le juger parce qu'il pense que si on le
tue on en fera un marty enfin après
l'élimination heatley de quelques
manières qu'elle se réalise
et bien lui romel prendra ou bien la
présidence du raje bec dans ce cas lui
cédera cette présidence ou bien elle
deviendra le généralissime désarmés pour
être à même de traiter avec l'ennemi de
traiter à l'ouest
car telle est la position de rome elle
poursuivre la guerre à l'est contre les
russes traiter avec les américains les
anglais
[Applaudissements]
vous allez me dire que c'est
probablement la position de tous les
conjurés et que cela va de soi étant
donné leur état d'esprit tels que nous
l'imaginons pas du tout ça ne va pas de
soi savez vous qu'ils ont discuté très
longuement chacun partage un avis qui
elle celui ci on ne peut pas traiter
avec les deux donc il faut traiter ou
avec l'est ou avec l'ouest mais un fort
parti parmi les conspirateurs préféré
traiter avec l'est et stauffenberg été
longtemps de cela
ceci par souci de réalisme et les autres
disent non enfin on va pas se jeter dans
les bras des bolcheviks mais finalement
c'est quand même cela qui ont gagné on a
décidé de traiter avec les gens de
l'ouest
en espérant que les américains et les
anglais viendront renforcer l'armée
allemande dans son combat contre le
bolchevisme
alors c'est ce qu'a décidé rebelles et
on en est là donc peu à peu tout est
prêt et on attend le moment où on va
agir en tuant hitler parce que
stauffenberg avait définitivement
triomphé
sa solution et puisqu'il n'y a plus
personne pour tuer hitler il a déclaré
et bien c'est moi qu'ils tueraient alors
les conjurés ont donné leur accord et il
est décidé que cet enfant berg qui vient
le 1er juillet 1944 d'être nommé chef
d'état major du général froome
commandant de l'armée de l'intérieur à
berlin et qui comme tel sera sûrement
convoqué auprès d' hitler
il est décidé que la première occasion
dès qu'il sera en face d'hitler il tuera
mais les conjurés ont décidé également
qu'il lui faudrait tués en même temps
que rim et il me plaît c'est beaucoup et
pourquoi bien parce que d'après la
constitution de ring et le successeur
dit lei
et que si goering disparaît bien il est
certain que c'est muller le chef de
l'empiré c'est ce qui se présentera
comme héritier alors si on les supprime
tous les trois en même temps on plongera
le mot nazi national socialiste dans la
pagaille et justement cela facilitera
les a faits du gouvernement
insurrectionnel
alors le voilà avec sa bombe il a
toujours cette fameuse bombe
l'une de ces bombes anglaises et il est
convoqué le 11 juillet à berchtesgaden
là où hitler passe quelques semaines
[Musique]
et là dans la montagne à laubert
salsberg ils voyent
[Musique]
mais ni himmler ni goering ne sont là
donc il nage il ment il ne déclenche pas
ça bon il n'est pas très content
stauffenberg se dit quand même ils
exagèrent pourquoi trois hommes en même
temps j'avais hitler à ma portée
[Musique]
le 15 juillet je tamponne berg est de
nouveau convoqué à berchtesgaden est il
emporte comme le 11 sabban et il a
toujours la même mission supprimés il
plaît himmler et gains et quand il
arrive ni himmler ni goering comme la
première fois ne soit alors il est fou
furieux
cette fois ci il n'en peut plus il va
même téléphoné à olbricht et lui dit
alors qu'est ce que je fais et aubrystes
répond bontempi populaire et green
occupez-vous d'hitler seul
malheureusement lorsque jetant feinberg
rentrer dans la salle de conférences
hitler vient d'en haut mais voilà c'est
que le bruit juste lui au moment où
stauffenberg lui avait dit et bien je
rentre et je m'occupe des clercs
seulement c'est dit hitler va mourir
dans les cinq minutes qui viennent
et puis ce que hitler allait mourir et
bien lui olbricht il a sur le champ
déclenché l'opération walkyrie et voilà
dans berlin
dans la banlieue de berlin au delà même
de la banlieue de berlin
les troupes se sont mises en marche
suivant le plan mise au coin ça y était
et puis voilà que stauffenberg est
arrivé et a dit mais non il n'est pas
m'as au moment où je suis entré des
partis et walkyrie qui était en train
alors le bris chute a pu arrêter
l'opération walkyrie
il a convoqué les chefs d'unité et leur
a dit c'était superbe
messieurs j'ai une révélation à vous
faire ce n'était qu'un exercice et on
l'a cru parce qu'on ça se fait dans les
armées des exercices après vendée ce
genre et chacun est rentré chez soi mais
stauffenberg lui est allé voir le
général beth qui lui a dit mon général
je vous préviens que la prochaine fois
je m'occuperai d'hitler seulement elle
général beth lui a dit mon chien stoffen
bien vous avez parfaitement raison et la
prochaine fois il arrive très vite le 19
juillet un ordre
parvient stauffenberg il faut gagner
leur père du loup en prusse orientale à
rester debout que hitler vient de
regagner lui-même nous savons que le 19
juillet tous les amis de stauffenberg
diront ils l'avaient un calme immense
depuis quelques jours il fait une
chaleur extrême à berlin surtout de
l'allemagne
que de temps
[Musique]
vous
tout le monde souffre de la chaleur
[Musique]
et ce calme immense n'est-il pas de
commande des amis de stauffenberg le
voit dans la soirée du 19 arrivé chez
eux et ils voient la sueur coulait sur
son visage et même me l'enlève plusieurs
fois le bandeau noir qui cache son oeil
sans vie pour éponger les larmes qui
coulent de cet oeil est ce que ce sont
des larmes la sueur il fait si chaud
mais s'effondre dans un fauteuil et ses
amis diront il a mis ses pieds sur un
guéridon pour eux c'est étonnant parce
que je t'offre une berge ne mettait pas
ses pieds sur un guéridon il les quitte
rentrer à pied chez lui dans le quartier
neuf ans et passe devant une église y
pénètre il pris longuement
[Musique]
et la veillée d'armes il va la vivre en
compagnie de son frère berthold
le lendemain matin 20 juillet 1944 il
quitte son domicile à 6 heures du matin
une voiture avec chauffeur est venu le
guérir ils s'arrêtent pour prendre au
passage son aide de camp le lieutenant
fenech
laquelle de ces serviettes et la mienne
elles sont absolument identiques l'année
on se sent toujours à l'aise avec vous
nous allons rendre visite aux fureurs
peut-on être d'humeur morose mon colonel
je pense elle aussi la capsule se trouve
le temps de charge et voici des pinces
pour l'écraser rappelez vous que vous
n'avez que dix minutes pas une seconde
de plus les voilà à l'aéroport de rome
ce torse ou à l'avion spécial les attend
ils s'envolent pour la prusse orientale
560 km
ils atterrissent à rastenburg à 10h30 du
matin une voiture les conduit en une
demi heure
hors pair nul on ne croyait pas que ce
nom repères du loup était étonné par des
opposants par dérision et qu'après tout
c'est hitler qu'il a choisi lui-même
alors on arrive dans un endroit bien
étonne
[Musique]
toute cette région est une région de
forêts de lacs
[Musique]
il ya d'innombrables lacs aux eaux
noires et puis des forêts immenses de
chêne de hêtre de pain et là au milieu
de ces forêts une zone de 8 kilomètres
carrés
3 cercle et dans le premier cercle on
pénètre en montrant naturellement patte
blanche tout cela est entouré de barrage
de fils de fer barbelés et des hommes à
l'unique entrée attendre
il faut montrer à laissez passer spécial
il y en a un pour franchir chaque marin
[Musique]
on
on ne peut laisser passer spéciaux
[Musique]
naturellement je t'en fais une berg là
pascal
dans le premier cercle vivent les gardes
ss prélevés dans les divisions d'élite
de la ss la division grosse d'outland la
division adolf hitler la division das
reich et habite là dans les bacs en
forme de casernes ou des casernes en
forme de barak comme vous voudrez et
puis on pénètre dans la deuxième zone
hélas elle est d'un machin il ya là la
demeure du marshall qui a éteint le chef
de l'état major
et puis de tous ses adjoints il ya les
bureaux il ya aussi la réserve de cartes
les archives il ya tout cela il ya même
à metz il faut bien manger il ya même un
cinéma parce que ce jour là il faut les
distraits et puis alors je tamponne berg
est arrivé dans la troisième zone alors
là imaginer deux réseaux le fils de fer
barbelés à l'intérieur entre les fils de
fer barbelés de la terre complètement
semé de mines et dans le réseau
intérieur de barbelés un courant à haute
tension de jour et de nuit
et là aussi une unique entrée avec des
sentinelles des sentinelles y en a tout
le tour
[Musique]
puis là aussi le laissez-passer à
l'entrée il est aussi difficile d'entrée
que de sortie
[Musique]
et il y à la maison d'hitler qui n'est
pas très grand mur en bois petite
fenêtre tout cela peint en vert et puis
d'autres maisons autour se sont tous les
gens les officiels et généraux qui
travaille avec iter
[Musique]
sur tous les toits il ya des filets avec
de la mousse tout cela est fait pour
dissimuler pour un avion ennemi
il s'agit d'un village artificielle on a
l'impression avec ce ver que tout ça se
font dans la forêt
[Musique]
tous
il y a une maison plus grande que les
autres le long 45 mètres de long c'est
la maison des hôtes et comme elle est en
bois et bien on l'appelle la baraque
d'ailleurs en bois mais renforcé parce
que depuis quelques mois les murs ont
été renforcées avec du béton et le toit
est une plaque de béton surmontés de
bois ce n'est pas à proprement parler un
abri mais enfin ce béton mais la demeure
à l'épreuve des petites bombes des
bombes incendiaires ou des éclats de
grosses bon alors plutôt fun berck se
rend chez le général fait le bible
fergie main c'est le responsable de
toutes les transmissions et c'est aussi
un conjure très important de l'avoir
dans la conspiration
parce qu'on a décidé que après
l'attentât fergie belle avait retiré les
conjurés de berlin et qu'aussitôt après
il interrompt près toutes les
transmissions le repaire du loup serait
complètement isolé du monde les amis les
disciples les fanatiques d'hitler serait
dans l'incapacité de donner des ordres
ailleurs pendant ce temps là le
gouvernement insurrectionnel
s'installerait et pourrait lui donner
tous les ordres nécessaires et là aussi
c'est capital mais leur approche car
normalement tous les jours hitler tient
sa conférence à 13 heures conférence de
situation alors qu'à y tels que stéphane
bern va saluer bien kate elle lui dit le
fur a changé l'ordre du jour vous ferez
votre rapport non à 14 heures mais à
12h30 pas dans le bon coeur mais dans le
baraquement du quartier général
et à ce moment là je t'offre hennebert
déclare tout à coup un monsieur le
maréchal j'ai oublié mon ceinturon emma
casqués et kate elle n'a même pas le
temps de dire je vais envoyer quelqu'un
les chercher ne prenons pas de retard
stauffenberg que je t'en fais banque est
déjà loin vous pensez bien que c'est
délibérément la oublier sa casquette et
son ceinturon
[Musique]
parce que quand ils les repas il en
profite pour ouvrir sa serviette pour
prendre la bombe
et là avec ses trois doigts et une pince
plate qu'il ne quitte pas il s'est
exercé sans foi ils brisent la petite
bouteille
[Musique]
l'acide
se répand sur le fil métallique la bombe
est amorcée il sait qu'il en a
exactement pour dix minutes
[Musique]
et eux rejoint au courant qu'à est elle
qui tient ce clip afin qu est ce que
vous faites
on va être en retard
elle entre dans la maison des hôtes et
en effet on entend un bruit de
conversation la conférence vient de
commencer
et pourtant je tamponne berck s'arrête
encore dans le vestibule d'entrée pour
s'adresser aux sous-officiers
standardiste capitale est hors de lui
mais qu'il dit je m'appelle le colonel
von stauffenberg
j'attends un coup de téléphone ne
manquez pas de venir me prévenir si vous
le recevez c'est important pour le
rapport que je dois faire au führer il
l'a dit à haute et intelligible voix
pour que kite elles entendent le mot
téléphone parce que s'il va téléphoner
quelques instants plus tard kite elle ne
sera pas étonné et les voilà qui
rentrait en effet il ya un rapport entre
1 il ya là au centre de la pièce une
énorme talent très longue de plus de 6
mètres de long et erraient au centre de
la table le dos tourné à la pente à sa
droite le général llyod à sa gauche une
place vide ou vacataires et puis tout
autour des généraux des officiers et
sténographe et c'est le général
aichinger qui poursuit son exposé sur la
situation à l'est et il faut dire qu'il
n'est pas gay cet exposé l'armée rouge
et pratiquement aux frontières de l'alma
et stephen burke a déposé sa serviette
contenant la bombe sous la table à ses
pieds
il faut savoir que cette table tellement
lourde est en bois massif qu'elle ne
repose pas sur des pieds comme toutes
les tables qu'il y a aux deux extrémités
de socle de bois massif sur lesquelles
s'appuie le plateau de latin et à la
place oui les chauffeurs berg est à
l'intérieur de l'un de ces socles il
plaire aussi se trouve à l'intérieur et
donc la serviette est à l'intérieur
il n'y a pas d'obstacle entre la bombe
et play la serviette se trouve à 1 m
revin nice d'hitler sous latin et
stephen burke cependant que le général a
ici une guerre continue ses lamentations
regarde sa montre il n'y a plus que
trois minutes et il se penche vers le
colonel monde
il faut que j'appelle berlin elle s'en
va sans que personne ne remarque parce
qu'au fond je n'en fais berck ont
sympathisé
steinberg est allé rejoindre fergie
belle l'homme des transmissions et
pendant ce temps dans la baraque
le général reisinger continue son exposé
douloureux ces lamentations et il parle
des positions de l'armée allemande face
à l'armée rouge
et pour cela il faut que l'on regarde la
carte et d'ailleurs y perdent se penche
vers la carte il s'y penche d'ailleurs
avec une loupe parce que hitler a besoin
de lunettes mais il estime que les
lunettes conviennent pas un dictateur
comme lui par conséquent il se sert
d'une loupe ce qui n'est quand même pas
mieux et le colonel brand qui se penche
lui aussi sur la carte
hélas à ses pieds il rencontre la
serviette de stauffenberg et ça le gêne
cet homme alors ils essayent de la
repousser avec le pied n'y arrive pas et
agacé il se baisse prend la serviette et
la pause plus loin derrière le socle de
bois et oui voilà ce socle de bois qui
forment une véritable muraille tellement
ce bois et massif est maintenant entre
la bombe et heatley il y a ce socle de
bois et puis ricine guerre continue en
disant qu' il est absolument nécessaire
que on décroche de tels endroits c'est
le lac de paille pouces sinon une
catastrophe pourrait hélas on ne saura
jamais ce qu'il aurait dit parce que
c'est l'explosion
la bombe explose et c'est l'enfer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le sol est jonché de cadavres de blessés
graves
cris de souffrance cris d'horreur il y à
même par les fenêtres ouvertes
deux hommes qui ont jailli qui ont été
projetés en dehors le toit s'est
volatilisé les murs ont éclaté et
maintenant de loin
stauffenberg voit les flammes s'élever
et maintenant une épaisse fumée noire
il avait aussi les hommes jaillir par
les fenêtres il avoue l'explosion et est
mort c'est sûr
et là vous pensez bien que l'explosion
averti les postes de garde des trois
heures
[Musique]
mais il est enfin des autorités
magnifique il dit les mots qu'il faut et
on leur espace alaoui aussi la nation
elle voilà à l'aérodrome l'avion qui
l'attend il monte dans cet avion
il atterrit à 15h 45 49 le fameux coup
de téléphone albrecht nous le
connaissons déjà mais ce que nous ne
connaissons pas c'est la suite du côté
les fins c'est que stéphane bern dit
alors où en êtes-vous de l'opération
walkyrie et rust et 10 mai on n'a pas
commencé quoi dit stephen burke vous
avez perdu 3 1 oui on vous expliquera
mais commencer tout de suite
j'arrive je veux lorsque je serai à la
benne de larges traces quand vous ayez
commencé l'opération walkyrie
on n'a même pas penser à lui envoyer une
voiture il faut qu'il emprunte une à
l'aviation et le voilà qui arrive à la
benne blanche traces
mais pourquoi olbrich et les autres dont
il rien fait pourquoi eh bien il faut
revenir au général fait le guide général
fergie s'est trouvé en proie à un cas de
conscience sévère il était prévu que del
annonce de la réussite de l'attentât il
téléphonera un correspondant de berlin
le général est il pour la lui a lancé et
voilà qu'au moment où justement il va
envoyer son message quelqu'un entre dans
son bureau est dit le führer est vivant
et oui et oui alors que 1 sténographe
non loin d'hitler est réduit à une sorte
d' amas de chair informe les jambes
déchiquetés alors que brandt est
déchirée de partout que deux généraux
vont mourir et bien hitler lui les deux
bouts totalement inde m
quelques contusions sans importance
n'égratigne sur les cheveux roux 6
le visage noirci le coup de luxe et
mervin rien évidemment ce qui l'a sauvé
c'est que la bombe a éclaté de l'autre
côté du soc
et puis aussi qu' il y a eu le colonnel
brandt qui a servi de boucliers
équivalent y laisser sa vie nnent le
colonel mandé wind hitler est vivant et
on s'est dit m'en fasse pas breizh
comment est ce possible eh ben oui les
vivants alors mettez vous à la place du
général fait le guide te fais et il
expédiait un message évidemment assez
curieux qui est ainsi conçu terrible
nouvelle le führer vie curieux mais
assez habile finalement parce que si les
nazis le lis ce message qu'est ce qu'ils
vont comprendre
terrible nouvelle on a voulu attenter à
la vie du führer heureusement il vit
mais les conjurés qu'est-ce qu'ils vont
comprendre
terrible nouvelle hélas malgré
l'attentât le führer est vivant bah oui
mais voilà c'est que ce message le
général qu'il qui le reçoit berlin n'en
retient que la fin le führer est vivant
il clair et vivant et quand il appelle
olbricht qui attend à la benne de larges
traces en compagnie du général bec et
lui dit chez ramiz surtout ne
déclenchaient pas l'opération walkyrie
ne bouge pas on ne peut rien faire
puisqu'il plaire et vivant et olbricht
est d'accord pourtant le buste d'un
homme entreprenant mais il se souvient
de quoi de sa fausse manoeuvre du 15
juillet de son erreur du 15 juillet cinq
jours avant seulement ça n'est pas
beaucoup ça view et c'est ici une
nouvelle fois je déclenché l'opération
walkyrie et bien si elle rate si c'est
pour rien et bien jamais je ne pourrais
faire admettre que c'est encore une
manoeuvre alors le brief ne fait rien
et c'est à ce moment-là 15h45 qu'il
reçoit le coup de téléphone de
stauffenberg et c'est alors qu'ils
n'hésitent plus il déclenché l'opération
walkyrie et elle fonctionne l'opération
walkyrie
elle fonctionne comme le 15 juillet et
les unités se déplace dans la banlieue
de berlin dans berlin est même loin de
berlin marque sur la capitale et ça
fonctionne très bien et jusque là on
tient bien toutes ses unités et c'est
alors que je suis en scène berg arrive
il ne perd pas de temps approche c'est
pas la peine
le général froome et dans son bureau et
le général froome commandant de l'armée
de l'intérieur ne sais rien de tout ce
qui se passe il ne sait pas qu'on a
déclenché l'opération walkyrie en son
nom lier et je tamponne berg avec
olbricht mrds officier qui a lui-même a
envoyé les messages à travers
l'allemagne se présente chez from et lui
disent mes jeunes collègues général est
clair avec les victimes d'un attentat
quoi hitler est mort dit from qu'est ce
que c'est que cette histoire qui est en
fait une berge
c'est moi qui ai placé la bombe au
général je n'en crois rien n'y fera et
d'ailleurs je vais appeler qualité alors
on le regarde d'un air un peu au dollar
pendant qu'il fait le numéro sur son
combiné
parce qu'on sait qu'on peut pas joindre
leurs pairs du loup et l'obtient kate
elle parce qu'entre temps il clair a
donné l'ordre de rétablir les
transmissions et que fergie belle n'a
pas osé désobéir 7 ans et carys t-elle
dit à from m'écouter from qu'est ce que
c'est qu'on vous raconte qu hitler est
parfaitement vivant c'est vrai qu'il ya
eu un attentat mais il est vivant
alors ils raccrochent aux médias écoutez
je t'en fais bien vous êtes un menteur
je te fais une belle lurette pommeau
général ces cartels qui est un menteur
vous le savez bien que c'est le plus
grand menteur de l'armée allemande et
voilà on va en venir aux mains
je vous arrête ils from je vous fais
arrêter tous les toits et bien c'est
nous qui vous arrête ont arrêté cet
homme il a trahi son pays à l'instant le
plus critique vous êtes allé trop loin
vous verrez que vous ne regretterez
société
et on jette from dans un bureau voisin
on la ferme à clé et c'est en route
c'est parti ça fonctionne mais voyez ce
qui est incroyable ce qui est insensé
c'est que ces conjurer n'ai pas pensé un
moment à faire occupé l'immeuble de la
radio diffusion qu'il n'ait pas pensé un
moment à s'assurer le contrôle des
centraux téléphoniques
goebbels le ministre de la propagande le
seul ministre important qui soit à
berlin quand il le saura dirhams et ma
petite fille la plus jeune de mes filles
elle y aurait pensé ben oui évidemment
ils n'ont pas fait et même lorsque le
comte
elles doivent se présente le chef de la
police qui vient dire je mets ma police
à votre disposition dont pourrait
envoyer les policiers occupés la radio
et le téléphone dont on n'y pense pas
simplement odyssée militaires disent à
ses policiers
désormais la police c'est sous le
contrôle de l'armée ab oui c'est comme
ça je tamponne baird lui a appelé paris
l'état-major de chute au magal il a
donné le feu vert
dans cette histoire il ya un seul
stauffenberg et à paris d'où va
fonctionner admirablement tout ce que je
tente nagl a prévu récit
[Musique]
et avant la nuit les 12 cents et c'est
ce qu'ils sont à paris officiers et
soldats sont tous arrêtés par l'armée y
compris le sinistre général hohberg
mais à berne est bien berlin ça
cafouille demande
il y à stauffenberg pendu près de son
téléphone et qui appelle tous les
commandants d'unités à travers
l'allemagne qui essaient d'obtenir leur
adhésion mais on hésite on comprend pas
on n'est pas sûr et puis on l'a confié
au général von has dans berlin pied dans
la conspiration
la tâche de faire arrêter ce ministre
insolite qui est là qui est le seul que
wells et phone house va envoyer un
commandant de bataillon un certain
reimer qui n'est pas dans le coup qui
croit ce qu'on lui dit l'airé mort et
soir était mauvaise
[Musique]
on y va avec vingt hommes mais ce qui
est inouïe c'est que ça ne soit pas là
des conjurés en chef il doit aller
lui-même avec des hommes avertis rmr se
présente il faut c'est aucun sujet j'ai
reçu l'ordre d'arrêter le docteur k
bulls qui préfère m'arrêter et se trouve
devant tiger woods d'autant plus assuré
qu'il vient lui même d'avoir hitler au
téléphone et qui dit mais comment dorais
maire vous êtes je le sais un bon soldat
n'en sais rien mais ça fait toujours dit
que vous avez prêté serment flins oui
monsieur le ministre mais il est mort
pas du tout les deux belges voulez vous
lui parlez imaginé cet officier
c'est simple comment parler aux fureurs
1 est et ils appellent leur peur du loup
il demande est clair qu'il obtient ubi
mein führer
je vous passe un officier dévoués qui
est ici à votre service le commandant
reimer et hitler prend l'appareil du
colonel reimer ça commence bien il est
déjà promu colonel ries maire je connais
votre dévouement colonel reimer vous
allez obéir aux ordres du ministre
grouwels colonel reimer vous allez
sauver la grande allemagne avant le
match on voit la rumeur que dans un état
il s'est mis au garde à vous téléphonez
heatley et le voilà tu parles
galvanisés il réunit toutes les unités
qui dépendent de lui et c'est lui qui va
faire échouer le putsch et peu à peu il
va nettoyer berlin de tout groupe armé
insurrectionnelle voilà où on en est et
quand tout cela est fini il se met en
devoir de marché sur la benne l'archi
traces et là ils sont tous réunis
discute sans steinberg qui appelle les
uns les autres qui essaye de recruter
qui essayent de maintenir les énergies
et pourtant le climat est
fétis mais pillay à la radio en sourdine
et tout à coup on entend à cette radio
une voix qui dit et voici un communiqué
important alors tout le monde près
pareil on tourne le bouton pour donner
plus de force aux messages et c'est le
speaker qui dit une tentative
d'assassinât a été fomentée par un
groupe d'officiers félon contre le
führer
cette tentative a échoué le führer est
vivant et en parfaite santé
il s'adressera au peuple allemand dans
la soirée ne quittez pas l'écoutent et
weekes café goebbels une fois créés mais
répartie et bien il a simplement
téléphoner à la radio ici goebbels voilà
le message que vous allez passer tout
simple et on le passe c'est maintenant
c'est fini parce que qui obéirait
maintenant aux ordres de ce gouvernement
fantôme
maintenant que la radio a annoncé au
monde entier qu hitler était vivant
alors on approche de la fin et stephen
berg n'a plus qu'un espoir c'est paris
parce qu'il se dit que si paris arrive à
contrôler l'armée d'occupation en france
toute l'armée qui est en france sans
larmes et l'ouest
hitler n'est plus rien si l'armée de
l'ouest bascule hitler saute mais voilà
c'est que kate a téléphoné à paris au
commandement de la kriegsmarine au
commandement de la luftwaffe oui la
marine et l'aviation
elle leur a donné l'ordre de libérer les
ss fait prisonnier par chitou nagl et
avant la nuit
tous les essais sont libres c'est fini à
paris comme à berlin
est ce plus curieux c'est que les
parisiens j'étais jeune mais j'en étais
n'ont rien vu rien su rien entendu rien
compris de cette extraordinaire
affrontements qui avaient opposé pendant
des heures ces allemands qui les
occupaient depuis quatre ans alors
maintenant que tout est fini il y à des
retournements à la bndes lerch traces
des gens qui adhérer à la conspiration
déclarent qu'ils ont été trompés trahis
on en vient aux mains on se bat des
coups de feu sont tirés
je tends feinberg reçoit une balle dans
le bras
on libère from fous furieux qui
déclarait bien vous autres les
responsables on va vous réserver le sort
que vous mourriez réservé à moi il sort
il rentrer cinq minutes après une cour
martiale s'est réunie vous a tous
condamnés à mort ça n'est pas sûr du
tout les historiens n'ont jamais trouvé
de trace de cette cour martiale et le
vieux général beck alors s'adresse à
frome mais d'y croire et je crois avoir
le droit de régler mon destin moi même
comme vous voulez ils feront mais le
vieux bec sort son revolver l'appliquent
à satan pétillent et la balle glisse sur
la boîte crânienne
il saigne il n'est pas mort et il va
dire je demande une seconde chance au
fait ce que vous voulez du froid c'est
tout juste s'il ne joue pas espèce
d'imbécile qu'il essaiera de se tuer une
seconde fois se ratera une seconde fois
et finalement se racheter par un
adjudant major
quant aux autres très bien la nuit est
tombée
je fais toujours aussi chaud c'est une
nuit lourdes moite
il descend dans la cour on les plats
contrat mais devant un peloton
d'exécution tout cela la lumière des
phares d'une voiture
condamné à être passés par les armes à
défendre y compris général d'infanterie
en brisant au buzz colonel et ses
lieutenants dont je ne veux plus me
rappeler les noms l'allemagne se
souviendra de nous non la sentence doit
être exécuté sur le champ et puis on
entend ce hennebert crier vive
l'allemagne sacrée voilà la fin de la
conspiration et dans la nuit tous les
allemands qui ne se sont pas couchées
qui ont attendus vont à une heure du
matin entendre hitler la voix rauque est
celle m
mes camarades allemands une clique
d'officier selon que ce petit groupe
panda voulu à sa vie mais qu'ils n'ont
pas réussi pourquoi parce que décidément
la providence veille sur moi et parce
qu'il éprouvait maintenant qu'une grande
mission m'attend au corps et pour
terminer il dit quand à ceux qui ont
commis cet acte insensé et criminel ils
seront punis comme nous autres nationaux
socialistes nous avons pu lire nos
ennemis et ce n'est pas une menace en
l'air dans les jours qui suivent sept
mille arrestations parmi ces 7000 il y a
des tas de gens qui ne touchent de près
ou de loin
absolument pas la conspiration est tous
coupables ou innocents vont être
torturés dans des conditions abominables
et on va les juger par fournées la
première fournée sera traduite devant le
tribunal du peuple
présidée par l'affreux phrase fleurs qui
traite chaque inculpé comme un criminel
de droit commun qui l'appelle en une
fripouille l'amour alors on enlevait les
ceinture et les bretelles aux accusés de
sorte qu'ils sont obligés de tenir
s'agripper à leurs pantalons ce qui leur
enlève tout moyen de défense
et quand le maréchal von witzleben tient
son pantalon et bien frais selon lui
lance qu'est ce que vous faites avec
votre pantalon vieux dégoûtant
cet affreux insupportable et tous seront
condamnés à mort de 100 pour la première
fournée
et on les conduit dans une salle qui a
été préparé pour les exécutions
on a attaché au plafond des crocs de
boucher ses hommes vont être pendu avec
des cordes à piano parce que c'est plus
long
pour mourir
il y à des caméras qui filment c'est
agonie affreuse ego belz n'aura pas la
force de regarder le film de ces
exécutions
ce film qui a été fait a le visage
d'adolphe hitler le 17 août
on nous a tous conduit à un home
d'enfants où il n'y avait que les
enfants des conjurés du 20 juillet et on
devait nous libérer tôt ou tard lorsque
nos mères seraient libérés mais en fait
nous y sommes restés jusqu'à la fin de
la guerre et même au delà les gens que
nous avons rencontrés dans cette
histoire gher de l'air qui a été
découvert dans le petit village où il se
cachait pratiquement tout ce que
j'hésitais à part quelques rares
exceptions comme fan club reinsdorf
tous vont périr en quelques semaines
4000 exécution 4000 un massacre
et parmi ces milliers de victimes
expiatoires
savez vous qu'il y aura aussi le général
from dont le tribunal l'estimera qui l'a
eu finalement une attitude ambiguë et le
général froome sera pendue
et puis il ya ceux qui ont
référé
ça donnait eux-mêmes la mort le maréchal
modèle le maréchal cloud est aussi le
général von stülpnagel quand il a été
appelé à berlin il monte en voiture et a
donné l'ordre à son chauffeur de passer
par verdun
et s'étaient battus à verdun pendant la
guerre de 14-18 et la voiture s'est
arrêtée près du champ de bataille il est
descendu à fait quelques pas à méditer
et puis il a retiré son revolver
[Musique]
s'est tiré une balle dans la tête
il n'est pas mort on l'a ramassé on l'a
conduit dans un hôpital on l'a opéré il
était aveugle après l'opération est un
peu de temps sur une civière on la
traduit devant le tribunal du peuple et
le freighter l'injurier il a été pendu
l'amiral canaris ça a été pendu avec des
raffinements pire encore que pour les
autres il y avait le maréchal rommel
marshall rebelle blessé grièvement dans
le combat de normandie on l'avait
autorisé à passer sa convalescence chez
lui près drum dans sa maison et puis un
jour deux généraux qui viennent le voit
qui lui demandent de les suivre en
voiture
il les suit un peu plus tard a coûté les
fans à madame romel le maréchal rommel
est mort d'une embolie
en fait dans la voiture on lui avait
tendu du poison qu'il avait absorbé on
lui fera même des obsèques nationales
et à ces obsèques pas rendre
maréchal von rundstedt prononcera un
discours qui contiendra cette phrase son
coeur appartenait au führer
[Musique]
on
alors on avait reculé au cours des neuf
mois de guerre que les hommes ont encore
à vivre entre le 20 juillet 1944 et le 8
mai 1945 date de la capitulation
allemande
il mourra plus d'hommes qu'au cours des
cinquante neuf mois précédent
[Musique]
si le putsch virus si l'attentât n'avait
pas échoué
c'était des millions de vies humaines
économiser c'était la plupart des
grandes villes allemand l'épargné mais
voilà cette providence à laquelle se
référer si souvent adolf hitler et bien
cette providence ne l'a pas voulu
elle a voulu que l'allemagne nazie court
tout droit aux coups francs et si
engloutissent
[Musique]